bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78 si
vous venez de nous rejoindre nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction
journal d'information locale dans
l'actualité c'est aujourd'hui selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
entre 4 et 6% et des personnes âgées ont
été victimes sous une forme ou une autre
de maltraitance à domicile alors que
vient de se dérouler la journée mondiale
de mobilisation nous ferons le point en
plateau avec l'association
gérontologique des hippies le vélodrome
national à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
prépare sa nouvelle saison les rendez
vous à venir avec notamment sur ce
plateau à jean-claude leulier présidente
vélopolis société recharge de
l'exploitation du site et puis là nous
irons à saint cyr l'école où le temps de
la fête de la ville les gladiateurs
étaient dans la rue elle succès est au
rendez vous avec plus de 3000 visiteurs
c'est une nouvelle enquête publique qui
démarre à montigny le bretonneux pour à
la réalisation d'un nouveau cimetière
celui situé dans le quartier du village
atteignait ses limites de la mairie
envisage donc un nouveau chantier à vers
les quatre pavés du roi le long de
l'avenue du parc rue jacques brugnon le
chantier devrait se dérouler en deux
temps à l'aménagement d'une première
partie de terrain de sept mille neuf
cents mètres carrés plus l'extension à
vers une seconde partie d'environ 1,7
hectare un commissaire enquêteur se
tient à disposition du public pour
recevoir les observations en mairie
mardi 16 mercredi 24 juin ainsi que le
22 juillet 17h à 20h les détails les
renseignements elles sont à retrouver
sur le site internet de la ville
selon l'association des couteaux
victimes les personnes les plus fragiles
sont en majorité des femmes à 75 % elles
sont là plutôt âgés en moyenne 79 ans
vulnérables
incapable de se défendre pour parler de
ce que peuvent vivre ces personnes deux
invités pour débuter ce journal deux
invités de l'association âgées y
association gérontologique des yvelines
admise le maître trésorière de
l'association dont soir et laurence
dumas psychologue coordinatrice
bonsoir et bienvenue à toutes les deux
en semaine du lundi au vendredi 9h30
12h30 vous avez mis en place un tel
service d'écouté de conseil
d'accompagnement afin de prévenir et de
lutter contre ces situations de
maltraitance comment on peut déjà dans
un premier temps définir la maltraitance
c'est pas uniquement physique
ça peut aussi être des violences morales
financière psychologique gic médical la
privation de citoyenneté
la maltraitance c'est ce qu'on fait mais
c'est également ce qu'on ne fait pas
donc il ya les actes mais aussi les
omissions je parlais de ce service qui a
été lancé à ses appels téléphoniques
quel bilan peut on faire dans les
yvelines justement le bilan alors depuis
2000 l'association a passé un contrat
avec le conseil général pour cette
mission de lutte contre la maltraitance
donc de plus en plus de dossiers de plus
en plus de personnes y compris les
victimes elles mêmes qui appelle avec
bien sûr des proches et des
professionnels également qui signale de
plus en plus les maltraitances en
moyenne 250
appels annuels c'est en augmentation à
ce stade il ya eu un pic en 2008 2008
c'est la création du numéro national
parce qu'il ya dans chaque département
peut-être pas comme dans les yvelines
mais enfin des actions similaires
en tout cas il y a également un numéro
national qui rend 3 970 39 77 la
fédération qui renvoie dans chaque
département des situations préoccupantes
est ce que vous estimez qu'aujourd'hui
tous les cas sont signalés justement
parce qu'il ya encore des difficultés
non alors c'est un sujet difficile les
personnes ont du mal à en parler même si
elle en parle de plus en plus et les
professionnels et les particuliers ont
encore du mal à en parler
là quels sont les types de maltraitance
que vous allez sauver dans le
département des yvelines
c'est comme au niveau national comme au
niveau national des maltraitances
physiques psychologiques financière
c'est généralement les trois
statistiquement représentait également
des maltraitances médical des ce qu'on
appelle la privation de citoyenneté ou
la violation des droits élémentaires et
puis tout ce chapitre des omissions
c'est à dire les négligences aux
personnes vulnérables mais juste faire
une parenthèse parce que pendant que
nous parlons il ya quelques images qui
sont diffusées c'est une publicité
québécoise pour sensibiliser justement
sur ces questions de maltraitance envers
les personnes âgées les personnes les
plus vulnérables
est-ce qu'en france il ya ce numéro
national de 39 77 mais c'est plus
difficile de trouver des publicités ddt
des campagnes véritablement de
communication pour ces problèmes là ça
reste un tabou encore aujourd'hui alors
je ne sais pas si c'est un tabou ou des
financements mais les pouvoirs publics
pour notamment 60 renseigner d'être aidé
et que qu'on en parle oui mais c'est sûr
que j'aimerais qu'on en parle beaucoup
plus mais en tout cas annoncé c'est
quelque chose qui on communique on
communique autour de ça c'est le travail
de l'association aussi juste que c'est
aussi le travail de l'association est
tout à fait l'association gérontologique
elle a deux missions une d'une part un
acte fondateur qui étaient des réunions
de professionnels qui se rencontraient
et échanger autour de leurs pratiques et
d'autre part cette action
de mav 78 donc est financé par le
conseil départemental depuis depuis le
démarrage et qui est soutenu fortement
par le conseil départemental
effectivement l'association implantée
aujourd'hui oui oui l'association se
développe elle elle fait de plus en plus
de choses des réunions publiques avec
les coordinations gérontologiques elle
travaille pour effectivement faire des
formations notamment dans les
institutions ou dans les ccas les lits
coordination gérontologique pour que les
professionnels du domicile aussi et
connaissance de tout ce qui peut relever
de la maltraitance puisque en
institution bien souvent effectivement
il ya un cadre il ya une obligation donc
c'est plus facile entre guillemets à
repérer alors que je pense qu'à domicile
il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup de
travail à faire à ce niveau là justement
qui prévient qu'ils appellent les
voisins aussi font attention les proches
les voisins les amis les professionnels
dans madame parlait les professionnels
du domicile qui peuvent s'inquiéter de
certaines choses ça en vous et en parler
et des professionnels les services d
aide à domicile qui sont aussi nos
partenaires avec les auxiliaires de vie
qui qui qui peuvent appeler également
donc faut une vigilance particulière une
attention particulière ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ya des cas partout mais en
tout cas faut une vigilance une
attention à certains signes détaille
quelques fois vous voilà une vigilance
et puis aussi un désir d'en parler parce
que le lit de la maltraitance et le
silence donc invité tous les
professionnels les personnes à parler
parce qu'on ne reste pas seul avec une
situation de maltraitance professionnels
ou particuliers
il faut signaler et puis ensuite il faut
intervenir on va en parler dans un
instant après notre question du jour le
micro-trottoir aujourd'hui porte sur
cette question est-ce un sujet tabou la
maltraitance aux personnes âgées tout
être humain qui est maltraité ses gars
c'est mon avis personnel tient quand
même à faire important qui ont rappelé
puisse en parler
avoir plus de considération pour eux ça
reste des personnes qui sont un peu
faibles
c'est un peu comme les cycles de vie
redevienne enfants non c'est pas un
sujet tabou on peut en parler il faut
parler
ma mère est en maison de retraite et je
trouve que les miens soigner et bien
l'encadrer
c'était un problème de société c'est
vrai qu'il faut s'atteler à trouver des
solutions mais on est concerné en plus
on a des parents âgés autour de nous on
a eu des amis qui ont retrouvé par
hasard en allant voir leur personne le
loup personnes de leur famille ficelé
sur une chaise je souriais fahy monde
afin qu'il y ait plus de contrôle au
niveau des maisons de retraite je pense
que ça je suis pas certaine que ça soit
fait violence dans les maisons de
retraite violence à domicile aussi on en
parlait juste avant il ya un numéro de
téléphone national de 39 77 et puis un
numéro également dans les yvelines il va
s'afficher une nouvelle fois quand les
gens appellent justement quels sont les
premiers conseils les premiers mots que
vous utilisez que vous avez pour eux on
écoute à nouveau ce qu'ils ont à dire
parce que il arrive que le dossier
transitent par le 39 77
et puis on essaye de leur faire mettre
des mots de particulariser la situation
pour aboutir à un pouvoir qualifier la
maltraitance il y a souvent une plainte
de maltraitance et également des
maltraitances associés comment vous
pouvez intervenir ensuite pour que
cessent ces maltraitances et venir en
aide véritablement au delà des écoutes
alors un partenariat avec tout le réseau
le réseau c'est les coordinations
gérontologiques avec des travailleurs
sociaux qui sont mandatées également par
le conseil général pour intervenir dans
ces conseil départemental peut
intervenir dans ces situations de
maltraitance
les travailleurs sociaux des centres
communaux d'action sociale du territoire
d'action sociale cds professionnels du
domicile des professionnels de terrain
qui vont aller rencontrer les personnes
à partir de ce moment là se met en
marche une prise en charge personnalisée
ça réussisse assez difficile à sortir
ces personnes de ce cette spirale delà
de la maltraitance
c'est plus ou moins difficiles mais
encore une fois comme on travaille pas
seul les interlocuteurs ça peut être
également le médecin traitant de
le quine et donc c'est des personnes de
confiance qui vont intervenir auprès de
la personne lui mes raquettes pour pour
la soutenir dans sa démarche est la
première des choses c'est d'en parler
pas de silence voilà avant tout à ses
messages clés ici qu'il faudrait à
passer ce soir s'il faut retenir quelque
chose par rapport au travail de
l'association si on peut rentrer un peu
plus dans le détail qui composent
l'association quelles sont les personnes
qui interviennent alors l'association a
été créée il ya plus de 28 ans
maintenant par notamment par des
médecins qui travaillaient en gériatrie
et qui s'intéressait beaucoup à la
gérontologie
elle s'est ouverte depuis un atout
professionnel autour de la gérontologie
donc tout le monde est accueillie avec
grand plaisir et ils peuvent peut s'y
intéresser il ya notamment des groupes
de travail pour les professionnels il ya
un groupe de travail plus spécifique
pour les médecins coordinateurs des
institutions notamment médico social il
ya un groupe de travail pour les
soignants et les travailleurs sociaux
qui s'appelle le groupe équipage et il
ya un groupe de travail plus spécifique
pour les médecins et neuropsychiatre qui
s'occupe des consultations mémoire de
manière à pouvoir échanger sur leurs
pratiques à pouvoir aussi réfléchir sur
les nouvelles thérapeutiques de pouvoir
travailler ensemble et faire du lien
aussi dans sur le territoire c'est
vraiment un espace d échanges importants
l'association organise des réunions
publiques aussi pour pouvoir promouvoir
la bientraitance aussi puisque voilà on
parle de maltraitance mais aussi la
promotion de la bientraitance donc
régulièrement il ya des animations qui
sont faites sur le territoire la semaine
dernière il y avait une animation sur
rambouillet le territoire de rambouillet
pour avec une pièce de théâtre
interactive
voilà il ya tout un tas de d'action
comme ça qui sont mises en place des
subventions de financement il ya cette
convention avec le conseil
le conseil départemental qui financent
donc le dispositif mavs et puis
l'association elle a ses propres
financements avec ses adhérents voilà
quel développement pour conclure vous
souhaitez sur les continuer à développer
le dispositif mavs parce que ça nous
paraît important et c'est effectivement
quelque un gros chantier qui a encore
continué et puis avoir de plus en plus
d'adhérents
merci à tous d'être passé sur ce plateau
rappelle le numéro un national pour les
maltraitances aux personnes âgées et 39
77 et puis le numéro un local aussi avec
l'association gérontologique des
yvelines numéro qui s'est affiché une
nouvelle fois merci encore quelques mots
deux politiques à présent la démission
de daniel guerre sont le chef de file
divers gauche de l'opposition conseil
municipal de saint cyr l'école élu pour
la première fois en 2008 il évoque des
tensions avec le maire bernard de bain
qui empêcherait son groupe de mener à
bien son rôle
il ajoute que l'opposition elle-même
aurait tendance à se braquer sa
démission a été annoncée hier soir lundi
le maire de saint cyr l'école qui
justement sera l'invité du nouveau café
politique de téléphiles ce mardi soir à
21h45 et bernard de bain et l'ue à l'est
républicain reviendra sur son engagement
politique sur ses priorités également de
ce qui devrait être il assure son
dernier mandat il sera aussi question
des relations est difficile de saint cyr
l'école avec son agglomération de
versailles grand parc émission retrouvez
aussi sur notre site internet
nous restons à saint-cyr-l'ecole samedi
dernier elle la commune est devenue un
véritable village gaulois après le
circle far-west cette année ce sont les
romains qui ont assiégé la ville avec la
participation d'associations du sud de
la france ce sont plus de 3000 personnes
qui sont venues participer à l'événement
william l un lutin vionnet a pu ou dans
les yvelines un petit village gaulois
résiste à l'envahisseur
samedi dernier la ville de saint cyr
l'école était métamorphosé à l'occasion
de la fête de la ville
romain gaulois et gladiateurs se croiser
dans les allées aujourd'hui pas besoin
de potion magique même pour le premier
d'entre eux chaque année nous on l'a
fait et que cette année nous avons
choisi l'histoire romaine l'histoire
gauloise un petit clin d'oeil astérix et
obélix et aussi peut-être donner à des
enfants l'envi découvrir et le latin et
l'histoire romaine
de nombreuses animations étaient prévues
mais aussi des spectacles entre astérix
et jules césar ont choisi son camp c'est
amusant ami andrew de trouver les
gallois à sacyr
moi même je viens de loin je suis
allemand non mais je vis à saint cyr un
peu d'histoire transporter et surtout
pour les enfants
je trouve ce temps pour centrer un peu
bizarre et ça fait bizarre parce que
parce que on n'est pas dans le village
habituel on est on est pas dans le même
buzz une civilisation à découvrir ses
coutumes et ses traditions comme des
combats de gladiateurs ou encore les
courses de chars
pour l'occasion deux associations
arlésienne spécialisés ont battu le pavé
jusqu'ici et avant les représentations
on passe par les explications car pour
eux le plus important c'est d'être
fidèles à la réalité
coladia terre c'est pas du tout et ce
qui est imaginée par le cinéma
télévision les péplums on est dans
quelque chose de très très différente
quand on l'étudié d'un point de vue
historique on s'aperçoit que c'est pas
du tout le phénomène qu'on imagine
il n'y a pas de condamner à mort ya pas
de prisonnier de guerre et la continence
et c'est parti je vais vous expliquer
quelque chose que je dis à personne
cours de char est très dangereuse donc
on fait des entraînements et les cours
de sharks ont fait ressemble beaucoup à
un véritable road au charme et on ne
peut pas faire une véritable cour le
chat asker je pense qu'il y aurait un
accident à chaque course
une après-midi de dépaysement total où
l'on apprend en s'amusant sur la journée
plus de 3000 visiteurs se sont rendus à
la fête avec pour finir dîner gaulois et
feu d'artifice il ne manquait plus qu
obélix et soussan guy les 150 classes du
département des yvelines ont participé
pendant une année scolaire au défi de
techno une troisième édition pour faire
aimer les sciences aux enfants de
maternelle de primaire
une exposition des réalisations et
proposer jusqu'à ce samedi à la maison
de l'environnement
quatre nuls à tort patrick jacques de
dixmude planeur montgolfière avion
solaire on l'aura bien compris la
thématique cette année la troisième
édition du défi techno ce sont les
objets volants 150 classes du
département ont participé parmi les
écoles la maternelle andré chénier de
montigny le bretonneux les enfants de
grande section ont réalisé un avion en
polystyrène
voir la fiche technique l'objet final et
toute la démarche pour réaliser
l'objectif est de donner le matériel et
eux mêmes ont conçu le prototype ont
conçu ont dessiné le prototype est
réalisé l'objet réellement apprendre par
la démarche expérimentale oui nous on
est en école maternelle on travaille
beaucoup sur l'observation sur cette
démarche
on teste les objets on teste ce qu'on
voit faire travailler les enfants à
partir d'une question comment ça vole et
leur donner le goût des sciences
l'objectif premier de ce défi techno qui
a rassemblé des élèves de maternelle
jusqu'à la dernière année primaire ça
fait appel à de nombreuses compétences à
des compétences en sciences a
effectivement pas cela il faut maîtriser
un petit peu des connaissances sur l'air
et puis des compétences technologiques
1 le trail des matériaux on essaye de le
faire avec des matériaux de récupération
c'est un moyen d'entrer dans
l'enseignement des sciences les classes
adore ça en tout cas celles qui
participent proviennent ils on invite
d'autres à partager ce moment de travail
au cours de l'année donc oui on reprend
sans souci une quatrième édition est
donc déjà en préparation
l'ensemble de ces travaux d'élèves est
visible à la maison de l'environnement à
magny les hameaux jusqu'au 20 juin
culture jusqu'au à 21 joueurs n'ont plus
que quelques jours donc le musée
lambinet à versailles propose une
exposition singulière les artistes sont
tous atteints de troubles psychiques lb
oeuvre se dégage une force atypique
sephora nomani puissante coloré et
expressive sont les oeuvres des neuf
artistes de l'exposition confluence
présentée au musée lambinet jusqu'au 21
juin
souffrant de troubles psychiques ces
artistes que nous offre une vision du
monde
intense et parfois en rupture avec la
société comme au travers des ciseaux de
virginie debussy ou de la sorcière de
karen
j'ai souvent des choses personnelles la
sorcière par exemple qui est basé sur un
autoportrait elle a une place dans la
société en faites quoi même si elle est
un peu mise à mal par fonds de la part
des préjugés quelques mois par rapport
aux personnages sur la sanction ce
moment face à face à un personnage qui
peut faire peur parfois
dessins peintures photographies
sculptures et vidéos sont autant de
supports travaillé au cours de la
résidence artistique précédent
l'exposition les artistes sont alors
guidés dans leur travail toujours
invités à le terminer et bénéficient de
conseils de professionnels
on travaille auprès d'eux ça a été
parfois d'apporter un peu de technique
des petites touches aux techniques quand
il est bloqué ou parfois des références
artistiques pour leur permettre de
rebondir quand ils ces chiens peu faut
des idées les encourager la finir quand
il avait des petits moments délicats
j'arrivais derrière et je leur apporter
un peu l'énergie que parfois ils
n'avaient pas la force de trouver eux
mêmes tout seul ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est leur capacité à créer
rapidement et tout de suite parce que la
plupart très sincèrement en une séance y
créer une oeuvre est ça vraiment chaud
sans remarquer cette résidence
artistique a été organisée d'octobre à
mai sous la forme d'ateliers
hebdomadaires qui en plus d'être source
d'inspiration se sont révélés pour les
artistes bien souvent libérateur
puis c'est libérateur à la mesure où on
pense à ces peut donc faire ça libère ça
libère le pas trop penser et se permet
quand même de le canaliser pas mal ses
émotions en se concentrant mais en
centrant d'une bonne manière
c'est-à-dire sans vraiment qui est de
penser qu'ils viennent interrompre le
travail
donc c
très efficace donner de la visibilité à
ces artistes singuliers souffrant de
troubles psychiques et leur faire vivre
une véritable expérience professionnelle
en résidence artistique et tout l'enjeu
de l'association art convergence qui
chaque année organise une nouvelle
exposition la finale du championnat
intercollèges d'improvisation théâtrale
de saint quentin en yvelines c'est est
en fin de semaine dernière vendredi à la
merise attrape toujours organisé par
déclic théâtre la compagnie qui a
aujourd'hui permis à la discipline
d'être reconnu par les ministères de
l'éducation et de la culture a décerné
son prix à 2015 au collège le village de
trappe devant une salle pleine les
élèves se sont imposés dans la patinoire
lors d'une finale disputée face aux
jeunes du collège albert einstein de
magny les hameaux pour remettre le
trophée benoît hamon le député de la
circonscription reportage à découvrir
dans notre prochaine édition de demain
mercredi à l'intégralité de la finale
qui sera aussi diffusée prochainement
sur notre antenne le vélodrome national
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines prépare sa
nouvelle saison l'écrin du cyclisme
français est aussi un lieu où se déroule
d'autres manifestations sportives voire
culturel bonsoir jean claude julié vous
êtes le président de vélo police société
en charge de l'exploitation et bonsoir
abruzzes goldstein souhaite responsable
communication et marketing on va déjà
faire le bilan de cette première année
première saison en tout cas puisque le
vélodrome a ouvert ses portes en janvier
est ce que le mot qu'il faut retenir ses
satisfactions tout si oui mais il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire
beaucoup de progrès beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de progrès justement alors
qu'est ce qui est on va tout de suite
rentré sur les difficultés qu est ce qui
a péché pour cette première année
première saison survoleront la faire
reconnaître cet outil magnifique comme
un outil culturel outils pour des
événements pour les spectacles c'est pas
facile de ceux de s'implanter d'avoir
une identité comme une grande salle de
spectacle c'est l'aspect culturel mais
sur l'aspect sportif y ait des grands
rendez vous je prends le cyclisme
championnats de france il ya les
championnats du monde aussi en février
tout s'est bien déroulé le complexe
l'enceinte s'est vite remplie en plus
les façades partie du point de vue
sportif il ya pas de problème on a eu
l'heure de gloire de des championnats du
monde ou à la fois le vélodrome a été
reconnue internationalement qu'on a les
plus beaux vélodrome au monde
et puis une pluie de médailles pour les
français le vélodrome qui est reconnue
aussi parlent par le bassin par la
population et les gens peuvent venir
faire des baptêmes avec les sportifs de
haut niveau aussi
ça aussi ça fait partie des choses qui
ont été mises en place pour que les gens
s'approprient la structure la nouvelle
opération lancée par le vélodrome pour
cette nouvelle saison justement on
permet au grand public de venir
pratiquer le cyclisme encadré également
par les athlètes de l'équipe de france
donc c'est le mariage qu'on met en place
avec la fédération française de cyclisme
en faveur du territoire pour les
habitants de la localité il ya le
cyclisme la bmx aux 6èmes journées piste
de bmx là aussi ça marche bien ça marche
bien ça marche bien ça c'est dit
beaucoup les ados c'est hélas il faut
qu'on fasse aussi des événements pour
rendre sa très populaire et ya des
choses qui sont en réflexion déjà
justement oui bien sûr des organisations
sur l'année 2020 2015 et 2016 on a des
coupes de france de bmx on a des
championnats de france qui vont être
également organisés l'actuellement on
avait aussi les enfants des écoles qui
viennent avec un assureur enfin et qui
viennent faire une découverte du
vélodrome de la piste bmx et concernant
le sport dans quelques jours 4 juillet
championnat de boxe cette fois ci c'est
pas du vélo quand nous en dit un mot
tout à fait écouter on sort sur le
succès de la précédente édition donc
avait eu lieu au vélodrome
au mois de novembre 2014 donc on réédite
à nouveau le l'événement donc en
co-organisation
et puis bah on espère connaître le même
succès voire plus puisqu'on est dans une
évolution constante et positive l'aspect
sportif qui ne pose pas de souci on va
revenir à l'aspect culturel et la
programmation vous souhaitez mettre en
place éventuellement les difficultés à
lever pour bien installer ce complexe
vélodrome vous avez réalisé un clip que
vous avez présenté il ya quelques temps
on va juste le découvrir ensemble et
puis on se retrouve juste après
le vélodrome national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du sport et ça
fonctionne plutôt bien et également de
la culture il ya eu des essais il ya eu
un festival l'année dernière festival
autour des cultures urbaines le festival
twenty fort avec des têtes d'affiché
américaines qui ont fait le déplacement
et ça n'a pas forcément bien fonctionné
côté fréquentation
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous avez eu
un sourire c'est un euphémisme ça n'a
pas bien marché côté fréquentation parce
que ça a été vraiment difficile
oui ça a été difficile mais il y avait
du monde quand même le problème après
c'est l'équipe financier il faut qu' on
est des rentrées est suffisant pour que
ces événements s'équilibre au moins sur
le plan financier
était ce qui n'a pas fonctionné sur ce
rendez vous par exemple source le twenty
fort sur ceux tout aussi fort je
laisserais bruisse peut-être devrait
donner plus de détails mais encore une
fois c'est à nous si il faut qu'ils
aient une reconnaissance de cette salle
comme étant une salle pour des grands
spectacles salle pour des événements
culturels et ça passe par quoi comme
quand comment faire pour avoir cette
reconnaissance justement c'est un petit
peu le une boucle il faut qu'on fasse
des grands événements pour que ce soit
reconnu et qu'on puisse attirer à ce
moment là suffisamment de monde et c'est
à nous de d'amorcer tout cela alors on
va le faire également parce qu'on a des
séminaires pour entreprises et on va
inclure dans ses séminaires pour
entreprise aussi des propositions pour
faire des interventions des spectacles
culturels des il faut qu'on fasse entrer
un petit peu l'idée que c'est également
un site et un équipement pour la culture
pour les musiques pour sur la twenty
fort qu'est ce qu'ils font je veux faire
mettre un petit bémol en fait j'ai
commencé par un proverbe proverbe pardon
que rome ne s'est pas construite en un
jour
alors donc ça tombe bien on est à saint
quentin mais c'est plus petit mais il
faut du temps donc on doit construire
notre image
en fait tout simplement vélodrome
national ne veut pas dire salle de
spectacle donc il faut prendre le temps
aussi de faire connaître la salle en
tant que tel c'est aussi ça qui met du
temps forcément et qui pour une première
édition d'un concept novateur qui
n'existe nulle part en france et en
europe
on a accueilli de 1200 personnes une
première édition je pense que c'est
plutôt pas mal pour le coup si on prend
la fête de l'humanité et autres
festivals les premières éditions
s'étaient 600 à 800 personnes
aujourd'hui
plusieurs plusieurs milliers de
personnes donc voilà sauf que sur un
écran qui accueille jusqu'à 6000
personnes dans les gradins
s'il ya que deux mille personnes ça se
voit tout de suite alors oui c'est ça
oui tout à fait mais on espère on compte
mettre en oeuvre tout ce qu'il faut ça
sera reconduit d'ailleurs le festival
très fort pas sur le même modèle je sais
ce que pour reprendre les mots de mon
président on doit on doit être attentif
à l'équilibré financier
donc on va plutôt réduire en fait le
montage tout simplement
et puis faire un effet boule de neige au
fur et à mesure pouvoir le développer et
puis voilà qui c'est dans ce sens qu'on
mettre en place une grande édition
en tout cas il y aura quelque chose à la
rentrée au tour toujours des cultures
urbaines dans le même style on est
plutôt sur la vision 2016
dakar - portsmouth prendre le temps
justement de zfs la reconnaître et
d'identifier la seule pour faire venir
plus de monde
est ce que les artistes aujourd'hui
aussi parce qu'elle vous dites il faut
faire reconnaître mais ce que les
artistes ont du mal à venir aussi tout
simplement lorsqu'on leur propose la
salle c'est plus compliqué non les
artistes on peut toujours trouver des
artistes qui viennent suffit de payer le
prix mais après il faut que l'événement
se sentent soit quand même équilibré
vous allez gérer pendant 27 ans ce site
c'est le deal du vélo police sur
l'objectif l'objectif c'est dans les
années 70 le va tricher ancien ses 27
ans oui oui essayer de le remettre à la
communauté urbaine en parfait état dans
ses temps avec éventuellement un pari
pour les jeux olympiques hausse est
nommé dans le cadre bien sûr moi c'est
lorsque l'équipement pourrait servir
enfin à sa destination cancer c'est le
seul équipement déjà existants une avec
le stade de france pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 bien sûr et c'est
déjà reconnu par tous non c'est le la
plus belle pièce de l'équipement
olympique déjà en place merci à tous les
deux d'être venu nous parler de ce
vélodrome c'est la fin de ce journal
tout de suite le 7-8 société édition
spéciale d'une heure pour évoquer
l'appel du 16 juin un appel lancé par le
président du club de football de trappes
qui entend mobiliser toutes les
associations de la ville une ville
secoué vous le savez ces derniers temps
et par de tragiques événements et je
vous retrouve demain mercredi pour une
nouvelle édition du journal bonne soirée